- [Instructor] So in the last
video we were talking about
the system of labor in
the Chesapeake area,
surrounding the Chesapeake Bay,
in the early English colonies in America.
And one thing that seemed
a little bit strange there
was that even though the first
ship with enslaved Africans
arrived in Virginia in 1619,
slavery wasn't actually
the dominant form of labor
in Virginia until much
later, in the late 1600s.
In fact, the vast majority
of laborers in Virginia
were in fact white indentured servants.
And these indentured servants
would come from England,
and the planter that
they proposed to work for
would pay their passage
across the Atlantic.
And in exchange the servant would
agree to work for that planter
for a period of three to seven years.
And this is an example of what
one of these indentures
might have looked like.
It's in old-timey writing,
so it's a little hard to see,
but here you can see
that there's three years
is the amount of time
that this person promises.
This is from Pennsylvania.
Kinda gives you a good sense
of how someone would say,
"Alright I'm gonna work for
this person for this long,
"in exchange for my passage,
"and it's a contract."
And this was a pretty
good deal for planters
because for every person that they
brought over from England,
they got another 50 acres of land,
meaning that if you had
the money to bring over
quite a few servants,
you could expand your
landholdings very fast.
And the other good thing about this,
at least in terms of the planters
was that these indentured servants
had a pretty high rate of death.
It was not healthy to live in
this swampy area of Virginia.
So quite frequently, planters
didn't actually have to
make good on their promise
to set these indentured servants up
with some land of their
own, some tools to work it,
because they didn't survive
through their indenture.
So if this system of indentured servitude,
and the headright system
that gave planters more land
for bringing over more servants,
was working out so well for them,
why did African slavery become
the dominant form of labor
in Virginia, starting about 1700?
Now when we think about
tobacco cultivation,
and later, cotton cultivation,
in the American south
before the Civil War,
what we think of is
enslaved African laborers.
And indeed, by the year 1700,
about 15% of the population
living in Virginia
was enslaved Africans,
going from just a handful at
the beginning of the century.
So what caused this incredible transition
in not only labor, but also racism,
to happen in early America?
Well there's one major
event that historians
tend to point to as a turning
point in American slavery.
And that is the rebellion led
by Nathaniel Bacon in 1676.
So let's talk a little
bit more about that.
So to understand Bacon's rebellion,
we have to backtrack a little bit,
and talk about the
development of political power
and tobacco in Virginia.
So in 1619, the Virginia
Company established
the first government in Virginia.
It was called the House of Burgesses.
And this is really important
because it is, in effect,
the first at least
semi-democratic form of government
in the new world.
In a way, it's kind of like a parliament
that was set up for Virginia
so that they could debate local issues.
And it's going to be
the House of Burgesses
and its later House of Delegates
that ends up leading the charge
for the American Revolution
more than a century later than this.
But as we think about the
way that political power
was distributed in Virginia,
you can guess who might have a lot of say
in the House of Burgesses,
and these are the tobacco planters.
So the government of Virginia,
although it is a democracy
of these land-owning men,
is still got most of the
power at the very top.
'Cause as we talked
about in the last video,
the power system in Virginia looked like
a handful of planters at the top,
a very small number of
free white farmers
who had their own land, but
nothing like the gigantic
tracts of tobacco plantations
that the planters had,
then a whole lot of white
indentured servants,
who have very little political power,
since they are at basically
the mercy of the planters.
And then, just a tiny
handful of black slaves.
And in this time period,
white indentured servants
and black slaves, black free
people, also a tiny number,
didn't have that much difference
when it came to political rights.
In fact, white indentured
servants frequently complained
that they felt that slaves
were treated better than them.
Which may have been the case,
because they were worth more.
Remember they were worth
hundreds of pounds,
whereas white indentured servants
cost just a couple of pounds
to come over, frequently died,
so they were less of an
investment than slaves.
The other important factor here
is just what it takes to grow tobacco.
Tobacco is a labor-intensive
crop, we know,
but it's also kind of a
crop that is extremely hard
on the soil.
It depletes the soil fast.
Which means that there is a
constant need for new soil.
And when you're coming from the coast,
here's our Atlantic Ocean over here,
and this is Virginia,
and our Jamestown colony
along the River James,
more and more planters, as they come over,
remember we have this headright system,
we have a system that says
that if indentured servants
finish out the terms of their indenture,
they get land of their own,
means there is constant pressure
to add more and more land
so you can farm more and more tobacco.
And you start going farther
and farther into the interior.
So what does this mean?
It means that land becomes
relatively scarce pretty fast.
And it also means that as white settlers
continue to move west toward
the Appalachian mountains,
which are over here,
I hope you enjoy this beautiful map,
it's certainly a work of art,
they are running up against
more and more anger and conflict
with Native Americans who are living
in between the coast and
the Appalachian mountains.
And now it's definitely in the interest of
the House of Burgesses, the
government here at Jamestown,
to make sure that there
is as little conflict
with Native Americans as possible.
Remember we had these wars of
extinction with the Powhatans.
That wasn't a fun time for anyone.
And so the House of Burgesses,
which is now somewhat responsible
to the King of England,
since he acquired it
from the Virginia Company
as a royal colony in 1624,
they have a relatively friendly attitude
toward the Native Americans.
They're hoping to avoid conflict.
And so their governor,
Governor William Berkeley,
spelled Berkeley but pronounced
Barkley, I don't know why.
He refuses to take on
another war of extinction
against the Native Americans,
which makes a lot of white
servants and white freeman
pretty angry.
It's the late 1600s now,
and more and more of
these indentured servants
are living to finish out
their terms of indenture.
They have now built up some
immunity to these diseases
that have killed so many
other people in Virginia.
And they're finding it
really hard to make a living
because the planters don't want to give
quite so many rights, quite so many perks,
to people who live out their indentures.
Remember this was a good deal for planters
when these white servants
never actually survived
to make good on the promises of land.
And now that they are, planters
don't want to extend them
things like a promise of land,
because land is already scarce.
So when servants are
finishing up their indentures,
they're finding it
difficult to make a living.
They often have to continue to work
for the planter they
had been indentured to
for very small wages,
they don't have land of their own,
they can't get started.
And this is a world composed
almost entirely of men,
so they can't even find women to marry.
And I think if there's
anything we've learned
from U.S. history,
it's that you never want
a whole lot of unemployed,
angry, young men hanging about,
because young men with a
lot of time on their hands
get up to trouble.
And one young man in particular
was this fellow here, Nathaniel Bacon,
who was incensed at
Governor Berkeley's refusal
to take a harsher stance against
the Native Americans on the west,
where all of these white farmers
wished that they could settle.
And so he gets up a militia,
full of young white men,
and also African American men,
to actually go after the Native Americans.
So this is a biracial raid
force for Native Americans,
and they raid Native American villages,
and kill many Native
Americans living in the area,
and Governor Berkeley wants them to stop.
And instead of stopping,
they marched to Jamestown,
the capital of Virginia,
and set it on fire.
So this is a group of
landless white men,
landless African American men,
who have rebelled against
the government of Virginia.
These are my flames,
the House of Burgesses.
They run Berkeley out of town.
And it's hard to know where
this would have ended,
because Nathaniel Bacon himself died.
And he died of illness,
like many other Virginians
in this time period,
so the rebellion kind of petered
out without his leadership.
But clearly this was a really scary moment
for the House of Burgesses,
and for the leaders and
planters in Virginia.
And they started to think,
alright well maybe this
indentured servitude thing
isn't working out so well,
because once these indentures are up,
we've got this whole set
of landless free whites
who technically have the
rights of Englishmen,
but we have little work for them,
we have little land for them,
and it's going to end up
with constant rebellion.
So maybe we should think about
a different source of labor.
One that will never get its freedom.
And it just so happened that there were
many such laborers for sale
on the coast of west Africa.
And we'll talk more about
that in the next video.